Magnus Carlson is a magician in his
victory over napomnishi Magnus found
seven only moves and a brilliant scene
to complete a near-perfect game of chess
yeah there's a Checkmate wow lovely
after it was all said and done Magnus
had an accuracy score of 99.1 with a
match score of 2-1 it all came down to
the final game Nepal was determined to
strike back and had the edge for the
entirety of the game but Magnus does
what Magnus does best and masterfully
defends a lost Rook vs Queen end games
he really has nine lives Magnus Carlsen
how does he keep doing this hopeless
situations many of us would have
resigned 129 moves and Magnus not only
forced the draw but secured match
Victory and that's why